2015 is shaping up to be a pretty good
here for games and that means it should
also be a big year for sony and
microsoft's a new generation consoles
let's dig into the part one of my two
episode series on what Sony and
Microsoft can do to win 2015 first up my
argument for the Xbox one microsoft put
the xbox one on a really good track in
the latter half of this year thanks to
two big changes knocking fifty dollars
off the price and removing the
compulsory connect as a result there's
now far less stopping people from
picking up the xbox one while those
unpopular features persisted it seemed
as though more than a few xbox 360 fans
from last generation opted for the ps4
microsoft certainly paid for its early
missteps by losing those fans 2015 is
another story though particularly given
the november NPD sales report which
indicated that more Xbox one's was sold
in the blockbuster month than PS fours
for the first time since the launch of
both consoles although the Xbox one is
still quite a ways behind the ps4 in
total sales it has the games leadership
and ideas to turn it around take new
Xbox bus Phil Spencer for example he
genuinely seems like a cool dude with a
really good idea of the direction to
take Xbox brought on in March Spencer
has since had the balls to admit the
mistakes of the xbox one's original
marketing he's actively worked to shift
the focus of the console back to video
games and away from general
entertainment while this is good for the
people who were sick of hearing
Microsoft tout sports and TV at their
2013 III conference it's also sort of a
shame that Microsoft dropped a lot of
the focus on the features that they
thought would be innovative and unique
to the Xbox one take the olin one
entertainment device concept for example
although it wasn't marketed very well
and lead games to think that xbox one
wasn't all about the games it was an
interesting idea Microsoft came to their
Xbox one announcement presentation with
something new all right they weren't all
necessarily good ideas but they were
certainly trying to do something
different now it's safe to assume that
we know the Xbox one is all about the
games if Microsoft wanted to sell more
consoles it would be great to see them
try and bring some of that all-in-one
stuff back without marketing it in a way
that makes it seem like they aren't game
centric at all the console as an
entertainment unit concept actually
works the idea of interacting with your
tech via voice and motion controls is
probably the future but since we've been
burned before by the old poorly
functioning connect microsoft need to
prove to us that things have changed
particularly since microsoft frequently
discusses how essential the Kinect is to
the Xbox one experience from the way the
console functions to the games and
services it offers it would be a huge
loss for Microsoft if it's decided that
the Kinect peripheral is unattractive
and useless given it's always been the
xboxes significant differentiator
Microsoft need to remind a gamers that
Xbox one is unique in the way it
functions the way you can interact with
it and how it integrates with your TV
and living room life one of Microsoft's
biggest blunders was not talking about
the game so I'd better not make the same
mistake it's no secret that halo 5
Guardians will be a huge win for
Microsoft when it comes out and it
should attract gamers who haven't been
all that interested in the xbox one just
yet but are fans of the series with
triple-a games ahead like rise of the
Tomb Raider quantum break crackdown 3
and platinum games as scalebound
alongside indie titles like inside and
below the Xbox one should have a nice
exclusive 2015 selection and that's just
the stuff that's been announced what the
company seriously needs to work on is
continuing
learn from their mistakes if Microsoft
wants gamers to see the xbox one as the
place for games they need to have more
than a handful of great exclusives if
Microsoft wants gamers to see the xbox
one as the place for multiplayer they'll
have to ensure upcoming online games
don't repeat the issues of Halo the
master chief collection fortunately for
Microsoft they've proved that making the
right calls like offering a lower price
putting gamers interests first and
proving that those interests will be
addressed and followed up with action
delivers better xbox one sales there's a
very real future where the xbox one
could be at the center of gamers living
rooms even those are already included
ps4 but that will require Microsoft to
make the services and features of the
xbox one office feel appealing and
essential without letting them feel like
they've abandoned the games leave me
your thoughts and i'll catch you next
week for my ps4 episode